yeah we we were down 32 and said like
okay now now it
now is the chance to just try it out
like it's a
dirty trick in my opinion it's
definitely not fair it should probably
be removed
it's just shameless of them it
definitely can't just go
you know unquestioned this isn't right
the problem is
you're never going to get another boost
that's that op but also wins you the
whole map
what if you had a secret strategy that
was so unprecedented
so dominant that using it might not be
worth it
honestly i am genuinely speechless it
it's made me so upset when you finally
used it
how would you feel i mean uh the map is
called all of past for a reason
smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's going to be a follow-up
shot i've shot all of my stuff you've
got to be kidding me it takes down
shimmer as well counter-strike has
always been a strategic game
but those strategies evolve even on maps
that have been around forever
your awp is fantastic they're ready to
shoot some ducks as they cross the
middle it's going to be a challenge
and apex not in this lifetime
he is destroyed but the boost that
fnatic used at dreamhack 2014 on
overpass was different
it's not an exploit really it's it's
just a broken map apparently and
no one knew until now and the lead-up to
it didn't help matters
we had a major issue in counter-strike
with you know some cheating
not only cheating accusations that are
running rampant but obviously we did
have
several top players get back banned we
need to talk about fletcher
i know that a couple of my teammates are
convinced that
they think they cheat i do not think
flusha sheets
um but i think maybe in the past
he
none of fnatic's players had been banned
they had their fans
but they had even more detractors it's
always easy to hate on the top dogs and
fnatic was the best cs go team in the
world
heading into dreamhack winter but once
they got there things didn't go so
smoothly
hell race is picking fnatic apart
finally there's a reply but it's not
enough
l races they take first seat in the
group oh for the favorites fanatic
16-14 victory on mirage what a game they
only got the second seed
and their quarterfinal match up saw them
face off against ldlc
the french powerhouse that was
considered second best in the world at
the time yes
young sherping are you ready it's ldlc
versus fanatic make some noise
this could potentially be a grand final
match right here it seems like we have
the top two teams in the world about to
face off in a best of three
ldlc took the first match dust two
marking the first times
they took a game one off this fnatic
roster but fnatic fired back with a
statement victory on cash
to even the series the deciding map was
overpass
that's it the perfect game here it went
to the third map just like we were all
praying that it would and this is such a
good matchup right now
overpass is considered a ct sided map
and fnatic lost their first t-side half
dramatically
12 to three it is really terrifying at
the moment here
pistol round means everything otherwise
fnatic could end up crashing out of this
quarter finals essentially in the final
map
that would be a devastating result for
them obviously and home
turf here this is when fnatic finally
deployed the boost
do they have a weird boost going on
currently yeah let's look at this
oh my god this is beautiful you can look
over
the restrooms as well the triple boost
allowed fnatic to see a huge
portion of the map from the ct spawn and
though they used it in the pistol round
for information
they had lost that too they are gonna
have to fight their way back to
blueprint the diffuse from happening
nbk down on the wrap and there's the
kill shot comes in with another one here
and it's gonna be a one-on-two
he just has to defend at the one
headshot he needs to pick up a second
one and he's gonna
get it double kill ldlc they win the
round
with that b push
even though fnatic had the boost
available they were running out of time
after the pistol round ldlc only needed
three more rounds to win the series
fnatic had enough money to buy a scout
and olofmeister's hands from the boost
position
that had to be enough all of meister is
still waiting the patience game coming i
can spot them coming out of the street
door as well he's here
he sees them down there straight
headshot they have no idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
there's gonna be a follow-up
shot all of my stuff you've gotta be
kidding me take stock here shimmer as
well
oh it finally works and now for that's
it if this is the comeback moment for
them
and happy will do a fine job indeed but
it is the return
fanatic they pick up the round the boost
works
the secret strategy immediately reshaped
the landscape of the map
ldlc just couldn't figure it out no i
think he's destroying there it is
raining down deaths from above
this is cruel and unusual punishment
without a doubt from what faster
even when ldlc managed to get on a site
and out of olof's sight line
fnatic managed to hold on the push is
going to be for a right now grenade on
down
and it does hit smith for 52 damage jw
follow up with a double kill ldlc
completely falling apart right now
smith goes down
it's 13 to 7. they tried rushing the
a-bomb site to push in before the boost
could get any work done
but that failed too this boost takes so
long they're going to rush before the
boost even happens now they're all the
way up to the a17 crimsons there
they had this so well time but it's not
enough performance drop
inside and that's it they are still just
a brick wall there's no getting through
here this was a great idea from ldlc
at 1313 a broken ldlc
finally called a timeout to see if they
could figure out a counter strategy
but it wasn't enough while ldlc
eventually figured out where olofmeister
was firing from
they never managed to eliminate the
threat he posed
they're trying to figure out the angle
once again here they're trying to see if
they could potentially get a cleaner
shot look at this now happy getting
boosted up but he gets spotted old
meister sees it coming
they've accounted for this fnatic
they're one step ahead
the boost gave fnatic the win it was
their eighth in the hole
in the purest sense it was very hard for
them in the first half they only got
three rounds it was
12 to three in the first half they lost
the pistol round on the follow-up half
that should be the
end that's when you lose and then they
pull up an ace up the sleeve and they do
it
for just every single round they're on
out flush against the double and it's
down to smith's
no chance at all fnatic they make their
way to the semis of another major
tournament here
pronounced with a final kill 16-13
destruction rain down upon ldlc
after the win fanatics coach devil walk
set in an interview that he believed the
better team had won
i mean i feel sorry for the ldlc guys
because they played an amazing match
they played way better than we actually
did
but we had more knowledge about the map
so we won because of that
wealthy certainly had their fans
especially in sweden
they had their detractors too and after
the boost which had proven so
dominant the backlash worsened it was
like such a
low low point i mean i have had
much hate through the whole career
pretty much
in csgo one but this this thing was just
like
it was so much at the same time and it
was very very hard for
for me as well as the others the
dreamhack admins
looking at the boost tried to figure out
if something about it was illegal
and fans on social media pointed to an
old 2013 dreamhack rulebook that
prohibited
so-called pixel boosts this would have
applied in 2013
except the current rules didn't prohibit
those kinds of boosts
the ruse that has been pasted on
a lot of social medias is actually dream
summer 2013 rules
so those rules has not been the rules in
the tournament
the tournament has the tournament rules
has been delivered to all the teams in
advance of the tournament
and in that route there is no
pixel boosting is okay the initial call
from admins
was to replay the second half of
overpass the next day
but the decision was debatable it's not
an exploit
it's in the rules that you can use this
boost it's not considered an exploit
it's clever use of mechanics they
discovered that two aspects of the boost
fanatic use were illegal
but also that a boost that ldlc had used
in the first half
was also illegal after hours of demo
review
is they found that both smith's and
olofmeister's boost
took advantage or or were subject to
this one texture bug that
that could be applied to both of them
and so they'd found their way to just
say
both of you are at fault actually and so
we'll replay the exact nature of the
discussion that followed between the two
teams is still unclear
thorin claims that ldlc refused to even
replay the second half
but the result that fans got wasn't a
replay at all
fnatic has four fates the match between
uh
against ldlc okay so this is final and
ldlc is through they're gonna face off
against navi at
4 30. even though both teams used boosts
that turned out to be illegal
it was fnatic who are made out to be
villains the community decided that they
weren't geniuses for their discovery
they were evil masterminds like it's
just shameless of them
and they're just a top team who
doesn't need to do something doesn't
need to do
exactly like bug using in order to win
and it was unnecessary
and they should replay it
in the immediate aftermath of the event
the team wasn't
exactly having a good time like let's
say it was
more more than half of the or yeah more
than half of the team i guess
that wanted to to quit several members
of the team
considered just quitting they weren't
really known for cs before go and
now firmly cast as the villains they
were outsiders
but they understand it was way way way
worse for krimz and all of that
haven't they were like coming in and
being
a new new to the top scene kinda you
know and
like being praised by everyone and then
suddenly in one
one game they are hated by the majority
you know
so i think it was hardest for them
but in the end fnatic stuck it out and
cs history is all the better for it in
2015
the same roster went on to win two of
that year's three majors
and fnatic became the only organization
with three cs go majors to their name
the lineup is one of cs go's truly
legendary rosters
driven by a desire to prove their haters
wrong
and make history fanatic are
indeed your esl one cologne 2015
champions winning back-to-back esl
events but of course more importantly
winning
back-to-back majors now three major
titles
in their trophy case the boost itself
also stands out today it's hard to
imagine that a boost
so powerful could ever be discovered and
then
somehow kept secret for months until it
could be pulled out in a major
tournament
what's even more unbelievable is that
fnatic used it against their toughest
opponent when
everything was on the line and it worked
as well as it did
he sees them down there straight
headshot they have no idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
there's gonna be a follow-up
now immortalized in graffiti on overpass
the oauth boost
is a reminder of the power of ingenuity
the pressure faced by esports athletes
and
the gray area between what's possible
and what's acceptable
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button